mise en place par l'éducation nationale
l'académie de versailles et l'union
sportive de l'enseignement du premier
degré cette journée dédiée aux deux
roues a réuni 450 élèves de cm1 et cm2
venus des quatre coins du département
des yvelines ils ont pu découvrir les
installations du vélodrome
chaque enseignant a répondu
favorablement pour venir faire cette
rencontre sportive ici mais avec
l'obligation d'avoir mis en place des
ateliers
pour développer la pratique du cyclisme
dans la cour de l'école
durant la journée les élèves ont
également rencontré un champion de bmx à
22 ans romain racing s'entraîne depuis
trois ans à saint quentin en yvelines
en 2015 il a notamment terminé troisième
au championnat du monde junior
aujourd'hui je partage la passion je
leur explique qu est-ce que c'est déjà
un athlète et ensuite après la
présentation de la discipline comment ça
fonctionne comment fonctionne une course
comment on fait du bmx il me pose pas
mal de questions combien de temps durant
un entraînement combien de temps
s'entraîne par semaine combien d'heures
combien de fois et ensuite après comment
se passent les courses
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines abrite une
piste de bmx de niveau international
piste sur laquelle s'entraîne aussi des
collégiens issus de la section sportive
de la couldre à montigny le bretonneux
on leur fait des passages pour montrer
ce qu'on sait faire donc fait des sauts
d enrouler et puis ce qui est rigolo
c'est de voir leur réaction quand on
fait des choses c'est toujours drôle
ils ont créé des démonstrations et
franchement c'est tübach épatant chaque
élève est reparti avec un diplôme et
pour certains une nouvelle passion